I think right now one of the ways
they're making our lives better is they
make people think right that's one of
the things video games are good at they
you in order to win the game you can't
just sit there you have to think you
have to think and engage and make
decisions and I think right now when you
when you talk now to the people who are
at the forefront of educational reform
all of them are talking about how do we
use these games I see how powerful they
are they're all picking them up like
some kind of sword and trying to charge
in to figure out how to use this to make
education better I think in terms of
improving ourselves I think that's one
of the areas we're gonna see at the
forefront but I think they're going to
be many other areas as well and we've
already seen the success of things like
the Wii Fit which is you know an
exercise platform for the for the Wii
and it's been incredibly popular in
terms of people sticking with it and it
really changing their lives I'm not so
sure but the fact that they've already
made I think two billion dollars selling
those things speaks to the fact that
this is something people want you you
know you talk to wealthy people who have
a personal trainer and they talk about
how effective it is this person comes in
and says you need to do this and you
need to do that there's a social
pressure in order for you to kind of do
this and not let the trainer down and
trainers know these kind of
psychological tricks in order to kind of
put you right at the right level you
need to be everyone will be able to have
that kind of personal trainer not only
just for the physical physical things
and exercise but for their education for
their hobbies for their art for their
spirituality for anything in their life
that they like to improve that
it's certainly true that there are
people who play video games in a way
that makes their life out of balance
usually these are people who have some
significant gap in their life and
they're they're filling it with
something in a way that is isn't healthy
some people say you know you
occasionally hear people make this
accusation that well you know that
there's these problems with video game
addiction and it's ruining people's
lives and the problem is these video
game designers try and make the games
too compelling they design the games to
be addictive and if they would just stop
doing that the problem would go away but
this is like saying that obesity is the
fault of the Baker's who are making the
cakes too delicious and if only you
would make the cakes a little less tasty
there would be this whole obesity
problem would go away right that's not
where the problem the problem lies the
problem lies with people understanding
how to take these entertainment
experiences and integrate them in a
healthy way into their lives
as as predominant as these
entertainments are in our lives
the the problem does not I mean there's
definitely a problem for some people it
doesn't seem to be an epidemic problem
it is definitely a problem for some
people and then certainly worthy of sort
of study and understanding about how to
best manage it